TIMES" FOOD COLUMNIST.
YOU HAVE TO WATCH.
>> IT IS AN ISSUE THAT THE
LEADER OF THE FREE WORLD FEELS
SO PASSIONATELY ABOUT.
>> CHIPS AND GUACAMOLE.
BASICALLY THERE'S A BOWL OF GOOD
CHIPS AND GUACAMOLE, I LOSE MY
MIND.
I LOSE MY MIND.
>> THE PRESIDENT DOES NOT MESS
AROUND WHEN IT COMES TO HIS
GUACAMOLE.
ON WEDNESDAY THE "NEW YORK
TIMES" SET OFF A FOODIE
FIRESTORM WITH THIS GREEN PEA
GUACAMOLE RECIPE, CALLING FOR
HALF A POUND OF SWEET PEAS TO BE
P
PUREED INTO SWEET PERFECTION.
BUT THE RECIPE LEFT A BAD TASTE
IN THE PRESIDENT'S MOUTH.
HE TWEETED THIS ON WEDNESDAY.
RESPECT THE "NEW YORK TIMES,"
BUT NOT BUYING PEAS IN
GUACAMOLE.
ONIONS, GARLIC, HOT PEPPERS,
CLASSIC.
IT TURNS OUT THAT GUACAGATE IS
THE ONE TRUE BIPARTISAN ISSUE.
JEB BUSH TWEETED YOU DON'T PUT
PEAS IN GUACAMOLE.
>> EVER TRIED PEAS IN YOUR
GUACAMOLE?
>> WE DON'T PUT PEAS IN
GUACAMOLE.
>> YOU PUT ENGLISH PEAS IN
>> AFRAID NOT.
>> AND THE TEXAS REPUBLICAN
PARTY EVEN CROSSED THE AISLE,
TWEETING THE "NEW YORK TIMES"
DECLARED WAR ON TEXAS WHEN THEY
SUGGESTED ADDING GREEN PEAS TO
GUACAMOLE.
BUT CLARK IS STANDING HER GROUND
CALLING